if you love cursed and want more fantasy
fun here are five titles worth checking
out on this week's binge guide
the netflix show based on the new york
times best-selling novel is coming in
fresh on the tomato meter after just one
season and its fresh take on the
ethereum legend has made cursed one of
the most talked about new shows on tv
one audience review from erica s said
i'm a fan of fantasy and period shows
and this
checked all for me it has magic love
battles and worthy villains and when we
spoke to the show's name
villain the shadow monk played by daniel
sherman he let us know about the intense
preparation
he and the rest of the cast had to do to
pull off the mythical characters
and epic fight scenes check out the
interview if you haven't already and
once you cross this show off your watch
list
you can add a few more starting with our
certified fresh pick
hbo's his dark materials this show is an
adaptation of philip pullman's acclaimed
book trilogy
and is all about a young girl who's
destined to liberate her world
from the evil that represses people's
ties to magic
and their animal spirits known as demons
with a stacked cast that includes staff
mateen ruth wilson
james mcavoy lin-manuel miranda and
clark peters
critics say the visual splendor and
exceptional performances of his dark
materials
definitely captures the essence of the
novels 16 hours is what you'll need to
finish season one and hopefully figure
out your spirit animal
if it's possum keep that to yourself our
audience pick this week
is the witcher this netflix show earned
a 92
audience score in its first season and
stars henry cavill as the monster hunter
geralt of rivia
who we follow as he battles demons and
lose ladies across his magical realm
and it's called who carries this show
that critics say at times feels only
half
formed but is teeming with subversive
fantasy elements
and dark humor which is why it's perfect
for cursed fans
season two is on the way but for now you
can binge season one in 16 hours which
does include some deliciously shirtless
henry cavill
from time to time for our throwback pick
this week we're bringing you the bbc
series
merlin this show ran from 2008 to 2012
ending on three straight fresh seasons
it's a reimagining of the arthurian
legend
centering on merlin a young wizard new
to camelot
critics say colin morgan plays merlin
with enchanting charm
and that both he and bradley james as
king arthur
give ingenious performances in the fifth
and final season
you can binge it in just under 49 hours
and if you want more aetherian legend
check out the 1998 merlin mini series
and the 2011 season of camelot
next is our brand new pick the netflix
series
warrior nun based on a manga-style
canadian comic book the first season
debuted in early july and is coming in
fresh on the tomato meter
it follows an orphan teen who dies is
resurrected by an
ancient holy relic and discovers she's
been chosen to join a secret sect
of demon hunting nuns with star alba
baptista leading the way in this fantasy
drama
critics praised the show's committed
performances and excellent fight
choreography
you can binge the first season in just
seven and a half hours and it could very
well change the way you look at nuns
from now on
and finally in our editor's pick this
week we have game of thrones
this epic hbo show put out seven
straight certified fresh seasons before
a disappointing final run setting
standards for how big budget television
is made
and breaking emmy records along the way
based on the popular books by george rr
martin
critics praised the show for combining
elegant storytelling
and vivid characters to create a rich
fantasy world
you can binge all eight seasons in just
69 hours
but if you happen to stop after seven
seasons trust me
everyone will totally understand okay
well
hopefully this helps you out with your
next binging session but be sure to let
us know in the comments section what
you're streaming
and always check back here for more
recommendations based off of the movies
and tv shows you love
on rotten tomatoes binge guys
you